congratulations on some unity guys it's
so much fun Billy it's gonna be a big
week when this movie opens cuz Golden
Globes just be a few days before it yes
have you planned yet like how you gonna
top that Cape have I planned out for the
Golden Globe yes you know so you know
they're gonna top there you trying to
it's just appropriate for whatever the
situation is I'm not trying to top
nothing I'm just trying to be present in
whatever the moment is I can't have that
pressure okay no it's true it's amazing
yeah so this movie I mean it's all about
female empowerment being a boss for you
guys who in Hollywood right now is
making like boss moves who do you see
out there because we're seeing so much
female empowerment over the last few
years who for you is really making boss
moves I will talk about that girl from
blackish who was the first she had that
idea to flip big little into little yeah
and that movie was great it was that
girl turned me yeah I love her so much
she's alive yeah she's boss she's about
yeah any more for you Jennifer
I think it happened you know I a few
years ago where I sir I thought Amy
Schumer kind of turned it around your
girls in a very big way and especially
and she was like one of the first people
I mean actually Madonna did it too but
it was like watching someone who like
doesn't take on the shame that
somebody's people like you know like you
know she was it was such a Power Move I
just saw her like you know people that
like you know critics or anybody she
just wouldn't take it on and I remember
Madonna not taking it on when like they
had like flat-out there was like photos
of Madonna long back or whatever and
they should have wanted her to I don't
know they were it was they were so
artistic photos Reverend they wanted her
to feel about and she just didn't she
just didn't respond she just didn't she
didn't take it on she didn't and I just
I don't know I like a strong woman that
just has so much confidence and and
believe in themselves at
don't they there so above the negative
proper that you know whatever and just
and and look how well she's looking at
well both women have done in this
lifetime yeah now that tragic moment
scene is absolutely epic have you guys
ever been fired in real life from one
job what was that I'm not gonna say
what's up but I got fired from one and
how did you react to it moved on yeah I
don't want to be somewhere where people
don't want me no that's true that's true
where were you Jennifer yeah I've been
fired like three times but one time
stands out because one of the guys fired
me when I was in the bath I mean like
set it through the door like I was in
the stall and he came to the bathroom
and he fired me let me go through the
you know but this is the best but he
didn't tell the other boss and so I I'm
walking I'm walking out of the business
and and I pass the other brush needs
Jennifer you need to be in your you need
oh my god Jennifer you're not in costume
you we need you in like five minutes and
I go oh yeah I know but I just got fired
he goes oh okay we'll take care okay all
right this yeah well congratulations on
spoon guys burning